yes calories matter and I think it
should be leveraged it should be some
step in a weight loss journey to help
shrink the size of the fat cell not the
number of fat cells that is a different
matter entirely but it shrinks the size
of the fat cell Yes Energy must somehow
be accounted for or reduced but
shouldn't be the first step this fat
shrinking Journey should start by
addressing hormones first in my view
because obesity or or fat cell
manipulation is really a matter of two
two variables the caloric variable which
is the only one most people look at and
then the endocrine or hormone variable
we know that animals will store or
expend energy based very heavily almost
exclusively on the way on the the
hormone levels and there are many
hormones that play into this including
adrenaline
um something you know a race car driver
would know a lot about hormones like
cortisol you know the most famous stress
hormone both of those are actually
stress hormones but also
I overworked those yeah yeah yeah that's
right and you're doing fine so you've
made it work really well but um sex
hormones you know progesterone will have
a different effect from estradiol all
from testosterone but then kind of
sitting on top of all of these
is the hormone insulin it isn't it isn't
too bold of me to say it is impossible
in a human body for a fat cell to shrink
if if insulin is elevated insulin is a
hormone that will promote energy storage
it wants to that's kind of the Thematic
effect of insulin from top to bottom it
will promote energy storage a an
interesting example of just how profound
this is is looking at someone who has
Type 1 diabetes of course in type 1
diabetes a person isn't making any
insulin and if they are under dosing
insulin or aren't on insulin yet they
will be eating thousands of calories a
day thousands and yet they are wasting
away Getting Thinner and thinner and
thinner because they can't there is no
potential to store energy on that body
because there's no insulin to tell the
body how to store the energy so it's
basically what insulin is doing that in
fact this will be the perfect example
across the hallway from my office here
is my laboratory the metabolism lab on
my campus we grow fat cells we are
literally growing fat cells in little
Petri dishes right now in the lab and we
will have these fat cells swimming in a
little bath of of calories there will be
glucose in this there will be fatty
acids in this culture medium in this
bath and yet the fat cells will stay
small and skinny if you will and it's
not until we start putting insulin into
the bath of these cells that they now
know what to do with the energy that's
all around them
cells don't know what to do with energy
unless they're told and it's hormones
many hormones insulin is Paramount that
tells the cells what to do with energy
now some people have heard me say this
and say well Ben's trying to deny
thermodynamics not at all my PhD is
bioenergetics I have an acute
appreciation for energy in cells and
organisms but a cell must be told what
to do with the energy that it has and
Insulin does that so to answer your
question after this long-winded
explanation the first step in my mind
should be altering the foods you eat in
such a way that you don't have to go
hungry you are nourished you're eating
when you want to eat but you are
lowering your insulin
by lowering insulin you will start you
will accelerate your metabolic rate
we've published papers on that others
have for decades we know that happens
low insulin increases metabolic rate so
you're expending energy better and you
will start burning fat much higher
because when insulin comes down fat
burning will turn on at a much higher
rate and so now you are learning to use
your own fat for fuel you're you know
that's what fat cells are it's like
we're walking around with these energy
bars strapped onto our bodies now we're
finally opening them and using them but
only when insulin is low so the first
step don't work against hunger just eat
what you when you need to eat but focus
on foods that will help your insulin
come down which is basically in fact I
know you've had people on the podcast
previously that have touched on this in
more detail but it's my rules are
control carbohydrates to help your
insulin come down don't get your
carbohydrates from a bag or a box with a
barcode whole fruits and vegetables
Dynamite but then the next two rules are
absolute musts because while you are
controlling and generally eating fewer
carbohydrates you don't want to be
hungry all the time so focus on protein
and fat which will have very minimal if
any impact on your insulin so that's the
first step help lower your insulin and
then once you've gotten to a plateau
if those fat cells aren't quite as small
as you want them to be now you take the
next step which is now I'm going to
start controlling energy coming in and
that is best in my view when done simply
through the lens of intermittent fasting
and there are many many ways to do that
but start with the low insulin step then
the lower calorie approach
that was a very cohesive clear and
articulate well done
um okay one question real quick
I feel like maybe this is a could be a
myth but
can we get rid of fat cells or can we
only shrink them and grow them yeah well
I'm thrilled you're asking this yeah so
in the average person and there are
exceptions to this but but the
overwhelming majority of people will
fall into how I'm just going to explain
it we will start making new and more and
more fat cells throughout infancy
childhood and and Adolescence puberty
then when we come out of puberty the
number of fat cells we have is typically
set
so this is going to be late teens in a
girl and then you know roughly 20 maybe
even early 20s and some guys you know if
a guy
yeah well so so it's flat line that was
a joke yeah I know yeah so it's
flatlined until from around 20 until we
get to about 60 to 65. okay and then it
starts to come down which is interesting
but that doesn't mean fat mass is coming
down this is fat cell number and so we
would look at this kind of drop and say
oh well then we should be getting lean
as we get old but depending on how the
person is living what they're eating and
how active they are
um what that means is the remaining fat
cells went from this big to this big
because they now have to carry a larger
part of the the metabolic burden because
there are fewer of them around and that
is when problems start
and paradoxically fat Mass itself isn't
the best indicator of how metabolically
sound a person is going to be are they
going to have pre-diabetes or
hypertension or infertility or early
stage Alzheimer's all of those are very
related to metabolic Health but it's
really how you're storing your fat if
you have fewer cells but they're all
really hypertrophied a hypertrophic fat
cell that is very pathogenic it's very
pro-inflammatory they're secreting
pro-inflammatory proteins and they
become very insulin resistant which
starts to spread insulin resistance
throughout the body or on the other hand
you have people a small sliver of people
who can just keep making more and more
fat cells and they all stay kind of nice
and small and happy and metabolically
healthy but they just have a lot more of
them well it's not the number of the fat
cells that's problematic it is the size
and this has been borne out through
Decades of incredibly well done studies
around the world a lot of the pioneer
your work was in Scandinavia we've had a
lot of wonderful scientists here in the
U.S that have confirmed these findings
again and again over the years so it's
not fat cell number it's fat cell size
and that's what as I noted that's where
most people that's how most people get
fat
um where where they they get to
adulthood they stop growing the number
of fat cells then any further fat growth
on the body is the hypertrophy of the
remaining fat cells and so you'd ask do
we ever lose them fat cells have a
lifespan of about 10 years and so in the
average person every 10 years a fat cell
dies but up until the age of you know 60
65 it'll just get replaced by a new fat
cell and then it's at that age you know
in the 60s where as the fat cells start
to die off they don't get replaced in a
kind of one-to-one ratio got it okay so
that theory is not a theory or that uh
that is not a myth that is true
um all right let's get back to insulin I
know this is like very much an area of
your expertise and your research
um so
I get a little confused okay so I
believe to that this topic is
challenging to comprehend to some degree
because
the metrics seem opposite like you want
to be insulin sensitive which sounds bad
but it's actually really good so like
there's a little counterintuitiveness to
it so maybe try and sort of run through
the basics of how it works how insulin
works and the role it plays and then I'm
gonna hammer down on some questions and
Curiosities around it oh yeah yes
absolutely
um so insulin resistance is my kind of
One Singular
um research Focus among among several
that we have always going on in the lab
but that is the one thing I focus on the
most to understand insulin resistance
and why we use that term to describe the
problem and it is a problem Danica I
mean as much as we want to say oh well
everything in the U.S we're so fat and
lazy and we're the worst not at all I've
given talks about insulin resistance
literally around the world and when it
comes to the top 10 countries with the
most people with pre-diabetes or insulin
resistance per capita we're not even in
the top top 10. so this is a global
problem now what is insulin resistance I
think it's best described as imagining
it as a coin
so I'm holding this coin called insulin
resistance and it has two sides on one
side is the phenomenon of insulin
resistance explicitly which is that the
hormone insulin isn't working properly
at all cells of the body
now I state it that way carefully
because while some cells aren't
responding very well to insulin some
cells are responding perfectly well but
globally we call that insulin resistance
so insulin isn't working normally that
might be the best way to explain the
insulin resistance side of the coin but
then we flip the coin over and it is
always on the other side you don't have
one without the other in this case the
other side of this is hyperinsulinemia
which is just a clever way of saying
that blood insulin levels are elevated
now to understand there's a kind of a
perfect example of this to understand
how insulin resistance
both sides of this the two aspects of it
is so problematic we can look at the
examples of
infertility and in women the most common
form of infertility is a condition
called polycystic ovary syndrome PCOS
in men the most common form of
infertility is erectile dysfunction now
but each of them represents one of the
side of the coins in the female with
PCOS that is the problem of the
hyperinsulinemia but she has insulin
resistance because they always come
together these two sides of the coin but
in her it's not the insulin resistance
per se that's the problem but her
chronically elevated insulin that always
is with insulin resistance and when
insulin is elevated one of its not only
does it tell cells what to do with
energy but it also controls the
production of sex hormones insulin has
its hand in everything and it's a little
known fact
that all estrogens were once
testosterone and then the ovaries or the
testes in the women or and or men and
men respectively it will take the
testosterone and convert it into the
estrogens through an enzyme called
aromatase now ovaries naturally do it
much higher than than testes do which is
why women have relatively much higher
estrogen levels than men do but insulin
will inhibit that enzyme and so if
insulin is high now her ovaries are
taking all this testosterone hoping to
convert it into this much estrogen but
it doesn't happen because insulin is
slowing down the reaction so she ends up
with too few estrogens to go through a
normal ovulatory cycle and too many
androgens or too much testosterone
giving her perhaps some acne or some
coarser body hair which is all a result
of the higher testosterone now again
that was in the woman which was the
problem of the hyperinsulinemia side of
the coin of resistance but in men
it is the insulin resistance part of it
where one of insulin's additional
effects is to help blood vessels know
when to dilate or expand to improve
blood flow wherever it may be of course
in the case of erectile dysfunction
that's obvious but when the blood
vessels become resistant to insulin's
vasodilatory effects when the blood
vessel should dilate it stays
constricted and thus erectile
dysfunction is a result
[Music]
foreign